[Music]
okay so I've been getting a lot of
people sending me things lately like
questions and stuff about how to stay
motivated and I think because everyone's
in quarantine like and time is blended
together they're like it's really easy
to get demotivated like how do you stay
on track and stuff how do you stay
motivated
I have to give myself daily goals like
the night beforehand I set it up where
I'm like alright this is why I want to
accomplish throughout the week what am I
gonna do tomorrow to get another step
towards my like final goal that's
awesome like I have to wake up already
knowing what I'm gonna do that day so
when I finish that thing I'm trying to
do that damn like I did it I
accomplished it now I can relax that's
true cuz I'm talking I'm like I'm a
jackoff four times today instead of two
times I feel like us people who are like
self employed which is everybody here
right we have a leg up on this
quarantine a little bit for ya our
entire professional career has been like
our goals were not decided or our well
our task schedule have not been decided
by somebody else right it's always been
like alright we need to do this because
we decided we need to do it cuz I missed
working at a job where there's days
where I'm not motivated yeah but I have
to be there so out of fear I have to
wake up at 6 a.m. because I don't want
to get fired
I got a drive to my workplace and then
like I'm there and I'm sitting there and
I'm like oh I'm glad I'm at work cuz now
I'm gonna be productive you're not gonna
jack off four times a day I'm not well
maybe I still will oh maybe it's his
goal oh that is a goal Wow
you want to go he's from 2:00 to 4:00 ah
maybe not this you accomplish your goals
that's what Matt one time my co-workers
sent me a nude and then I jacked off in
the bathroom and then after a worker
yeah we why do you just think about your
dick man
you don't have to think about my dick
you could just think about the co-worker
being naked are you a nude by the way
no but I've probably seen his dick more
than I've ever wanted if you didn't
check off your okay I've never seen it
hard
I saw it covered in sriracha oh wow I've
had to film hot Bart stick me too
many of our crew you know I've had
allowed dick yet no Bart stick I've seen
his balls dipped in a cup of milk should
be vlogging and then she turns around in
the bathroom I don't I apologize in the
video you don't know you don't even know
you're filming in the shower just died
in there watching there's been times
when Bart would pee and people would
have to film the pee wait why hello /
farts JK bro
okay there's so many things I think
within our company that if anyone just
wanted to do a sexual harassment it
could happen documented oh yeah even our
group text conversations but I feel like
with that you'd have backtracking
because the people that actually play
the videos like yeah that's a good idea
are the ones filming it and half that
did it that could be true yeah but in
most cases it's unwanted and it's just
happen or the work more planned or
invented in the moment just your world
oh just kidding yes it's a good question
though because I get that too is life a
lot of people right now I think they
don't have direction and and it's
because like you said like well what
Nelson mentioned is that I think a lot
of people are working or going to school
or they go throughout lives with someone
telling them and giving them structure
this is what's expected out of you this
is the assignments you need to turn in
this is that right so then you stop or
you don't even know how to motivate
yourself to create work for yourself
right and that's what I really miss is
that someone telling me what to do yeah
I think a lot of people realize that
like when they're having nothing to do
that they actually miss work I people
are posting all the times like I can't
believe I'm saying this I want to go
back to my job yeah people crave
structure
you need a purpose yeah they need
purpose you need structure and deadlines
man if you give yourself a deadline so
even if you're just doing something
hobby wise it's like I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna write this book and write this
movie if you give yourself a deadline
that you have to get it done by that is
the best thing you can do for it to
motivate yourself like because you're
because especially if you're working for
yourself with something and by that I
mean if you're listening to me like well
I'll turn em off my brain now because I
work for somebody else I'm talking about
you're working for yourself if you're
trying to accomplish your goal for your
life yeah right so it's like if you can
just say I have to get it done by this
time then you are you know accountable
to something remember Steve I was on the
livestream and I told you I wasn't gonna
jack off and for two days I did it you
did so good was that the goal two days
why still played with it but then Steve
says dice I didn't I did yes he didn't
come every day yeah yeah I know but I
don't wanna think about his dick all the
time
okay just one more time stop thinking
about my day just just he might stick
one more time because then the next day
on our live stream he he admitted he had
the balls to say you know what I feel
yeah yeah do you know what geo when he
brings up masturbating I don't know why
but because when I think about
masturbating I think about my own self
so I just think about him robbing I
think not of myself because I gross
myself out I think a lot of people in
this room dude
I think of chimpanzee jacking off and I
laugh you also think of my team now
because you guys share the same man oil
nope oh it's difficult for me to be
aroused and think of even my own dick
mmm I picture everyone in this room
having sex I have honestly done that
well you to horny girl no they turn me
on it's it's more the science hat is
that curiosity it's not like I'm not
going oh yeah my mind can't even go
there because I'll barf I'm picturing
you and Bart having sex right now
[Laughter]
does Bart look confused though he has no
facial expressions I'll give you a hint
there's no facial Explorer looks like as
I'm thinking about doing push-ups or
something that's it
we gotta truck sets and reps all the
time the best sex that ought to go is
back
the best thing about Bart is we could
give him the note that he needs more
facial expressions during sex and he'll
work on this he'll be in front of the me
the next morning 5:00 a.m. like our just
doing
how many people would do that I know no
not many not he's got the E in effort
yeah yeah for me like when I get asked
this question like I think because when
you're working at a job you're like God
it would be so good and not have to show
up every day be so good at like just be
out like this yeah and then you get
there and like I've been self-employed
for seven years full-time now and the
first year is like oh [ __ ] it's all up
to me like hard I don't get the things
done then I don't make any money and I
can't pay my bills and then you almost
start daydreaming about going back to a
job because you're like at least I know
what I'm doing there cuz right now it's
like I don't know the right thing to do
yeah and so I think mostly I've been
motivated out of fear because I'm like I
remember being broke as [ __ ] and I'm
like I don't want to go back to that
life so I felt like I created this work
addiction because I'm like I feel like
if I stopped working I'm gonna go broke
but yeah yeah and not be able to pay my
bills or something like that have you
ever gotten to the point where you have
so much money in your bank account then
you could last for five years straight
and then you get sad cuz you don't have
that Empire I have not reached that
point yet but maybe one day job I know
what that feeling is yes so so a couple
years ago right I thought all I needed
was like a quarter million dollars my
bank account this is this like I just
needed everything to set me off and be
full to be okay I actually got hella
depressed and I don't even want to sound
like those guys that are like oh I'm so
privileged I don't know how to deal with
it right it's it's literally you don't
feel like you're living for something
yet cuz I didn't realize that I was so
motivated by fear that once you got
security yeah I don't know what drives
you anymore
like those athletes that become first
place right and then like they don't
know what else to live for I never felt
sadder than after I accomplished my goal
which was my [ __ ] childhood goal of
starring in a movie then you do it and
you don't know what to do next
yeah but whew I played this two people
are the one they're like oh that's white
privilege or that's a specific type of
privilege because you should be telling
them how you actually feel because then
people aren't motivated by just money
alone that's what I want to tell me what
there's that it's never gonna be good
enough right so you can be like I I
always thought hey as long as as long as
I'm financially stable I have this much
money I can buy all the things I want I
would feel relaxed but it didn't relax
you know why because people think that
happiness is getting rid of all their
problems but happiness is actually from
solving problems problems to solve you
don't you're not happy anymore and I
actually became a lot happier when I
made a very risky investment move and I
went down to zero and I owed $100,000
and I was in a mode a panic crisis mode
mm-hmm I didn't know why but that made
me feel a lot of your solving again
you're solving a problem again which
most people will be depressed if they
were in the position well you can't be
but it's also a motivator conflict is a
prime motivator
you know also once you've made that much
money like you know you have the
confidence almost that you can make it
again right so you get all the yeah
you're right as well a lot of people
that get super rich they make a million
dollars and then they go bankrupt right
they make their second million dollars
way faster than the first missions
because they know how and they know all
the ways they failed before and it's
also a different mindset now mm-hmm
we talked about this subject two weeks
ago right like passions and motivations
and I think the problem is when you make
that one goal your motivation rather
than finding out what is motivating that
goal and making that what you're
passionate about you know so once you
finish that goal you still know what's
motivating you and what why you decided
to make that goal in the first place cuz
you'll have an infinite amount of goals
based on if you realize what motivated
that first goal right well if you
finished that one thing then you're
gonna be lost without purpose and also
some days I'm
motivated like but I just do it anyway
and sometimes you start off not
motivated and then you do the thing you
said you were gonna do and then you
start getting into it you get a flow
state and then you are motivated I think
that's what helped the most is you can't
think your way into motivation you just
got a physically start started doing it
yeah I don't wait for it to happen to
you randomly I went through years of
battling with that cuz I would sit here
and I would think for motivation to have
yeah but then a lot of the times if you
just start cleaning your room a little
bit then before you know it you're
cleaning the whole house it's a dot yeah
same with work and I just get to the gym
and you start yeah a little bit here
it's gonna keep your promise that's your
stuff the biggest thing it's like if you
really want to do it just just do it and
if I'm not motivated I'll just go on a
walk and sometimes just getting into the
movement yeah you just don't want to
stop moving so after you're done with
the walk you're like old now I call all
clean this part of the house would say
that is the secret that I wish I knew
way earlier is the physical state mm-hmm
is just deal with that first or do the
little thing like if you want to write a
book just write a paragraph mm-hmm and
then it'll start to snowball but then a
lot of the times we try to figure it out
yeah even [ __ ] do it and that is what
I battled with over 14 years starting is
me we're training so you want to lose
weight or like just get it to working
out
it's obviously the first week is like
this is horrible but then you find
pleasure in that pain well they people
see the mountain they're like how am I
gonna lose 15 pounds or like they they
see the end from here and they're like
it seems like huge it's like no don't
focus on the losing 15 pounds focus on
the like how do I get on the howl and
set up the water how do I move my body
for 30 minutes today I'm the opposite
where I'm like I I have like the end
goal I do set up maybe a little like
tick marks or whatever and I can make
like a checklist but I think just
starting and knowing that it is a hurdle
and if I don't start now it's gonna take
longer to get there and cuz that for me
I like getting motivated by the
cold-turkey method but it's just like
just start it's gonna be hard but it's
gonna get easier so it's also important
to know yourself like I realize I thrive
in risk and panic sometimes yeah and for
other people maybe they like calmer but
or some people like a huge commitment
and others might want just baby steps
for me
anger anger was my biggest motivator and
once I realized that about myself yeah
exactly hate hate could be one huge my
anger for me gets me going
and it helps me focus that in the right
way like I look at my entire body of
work and I only see what I could have
done better and it makes me [ __ ] mad
right and so so I take it from there to
the next one and it's like I'll get
better on the next one and then it's
like you know I can't watch anything
I've made these days I just can't so
when you watch Star Wars do you relate
to the dark side
I guess again it's motivated by the dark
equals dark side
yes yeah that guy he had some sick he
has some sick [ __ ] has some good ideas
[Music]